[Music]
foreign
I'm Steve Brunton and I'm really excited
to introduce you to one of my favorite
topics in all of math which is
differential equations
so this is a short course I'm putting
together this is actually part of a
larger sequence in my engineering math
course that I've been offering for about
the last 10 years this is one of my
favorite courses to teach is math to
engineers
and the part one kind of the entry level
for this as I see it is really this
topic of differential equations okay so
I fell in love with differential
equations it opened up a whole world of
possibilities of things you could model
of things you can understand of things
you can build with math with equations
and so kind of I feel like this is the
next logical step after calculus so if
you like calculus and if you like the
way that you can model the world with
how things you know change in time this
is kind of the next step in that
progression differential equations we're
going to use calculus to model how
systems change in time okay so this this
is kind of one of my favorite examples
uh of a chaotic dynamical system or
differential equation called the lorentz
system which was introduced about a half
a century ago a little bit longer than
that to model chaotic convection in the
atmosphere so we'll talk about this a
lot later
this course
is meant to be about a seven week uh
Series in a university class so that's
about 20 hours of lectures that I'm
going to be putting together here and
kind of all that I assume that you know
is that you have you know taken a
Calculus class I don't even assume that
you remember most of your Calculus class
you know I'm assuming that you are smart
and motivated that you have seen some of
these calculus Concepts before but maybe
you don't remember them and I'm going to
build everything up from scratch into
this pretty rich and complex world of
differential equations
okay good
um so in this video I'm going to kind of
lay out what are the topics we're going
to cover in the class what are some of
the applications that we can open up and
enable with this kind of of analysis of
differential equations I'm inherently
going to be folding in linear algebra
because the way I see it really these
two topics should be taught completely
together you can't understand
differential equations without linear
algebra and differential equations are
probably the best motivating example to
understand linear algebra better so for
me linear algebra is a is a piece it's a
part of differential equations you can't
separate those so we'll talk about
topics applications
I'll tell you kind of where this fits in
so I've already told you this is kind of
the next logical piece after calculus
but I'll tell you also what's next Once
you learn these differential equations
what new fields of math are going to be
open up to you and I'll tell you how to
get some of the resources that we're
going to use throughout this class so in
the video video description below I'm
going to put links to all of the code
for the entire class everything's going
to be available in Python and Matlab
there will be PDF notes for all of the
lectures so every single video is going
to have a lecture notes with it there
will be a course website I'm planning on
writing you know a short book on this
topic so maybe by the time you watch
this for those of you time travelers
from the future you know maybe there are
actually be you know a typed up book
that you can you can reference but all
of that will be in the the video
description
good um and I'll tell you why I think
this is important and interesting it's
one of my favorite topics
okay so overview of objects that are
going to be covered in this uh this
course and this kind of 20 hours of
material that fits into this larger
engineering math framework I'm going to
start with a simple review of calculus
this will be super brief super short but
you know again I'm going to assume
you've taken calculus but maybe you
don't remember it or maybe it wasn't
taught you know in a way that was
motivated by applications so I'm going
to you know start really really simple
remind you what the derivative power you
know the derivative is power rule chain
rule but I'm going to also really kind
of
early on focus on the Taylor series so
you have some intuition for what this
this means and how this works because
we're going to use Taylor series quite a
lot and how we understand you know
Solutions of differential equations
we're actually going to derive
exponential functions and Sines and
cosines as Solutions of differential
equations using Taylor series so this
isn't going to be very long but it's
very important so if you need to brush
up on calculus definitely you know don't
skip these lectures
and then I'm going to jump right into a
system simple simple ordinary
differential equations so really simple
uh differential equations of a single
variable X so X is some quantity that's
changing in time that I care about maybe
it's the population of bunnies and those
population of bunnies is growing and
growing and growing so the rate of
change of X my population the number of
bunnies in my population is going to
equal it's going to be a function of my
current population so if I have a
hundred bunnies they're going to grow
faster than if I only have 10 bunnies if
I have a thousand buddies they'll grow
even faster still so the rate of change
of my population in time is a function
it's a linear proportional to the number
of bunnies I have in my population
currently and so this is going to be
like the simplest simplest entry
ode ordinary differential equation and
from this we're going to look at what
the solutions are how to analyze them
how to interpret them and then we're
going to generalize that into much more
complicated Rich differential equations
so here dot just means derivative and
time that's shorthand for D DT of X
where X is the state of my system or
some variable that I'm keeping track of
as it evolves in time like a bunny
population or like you know the
radioactive decay of plutonium or
uranium or something like that
so we'll start off real simple and build
everything from scratch
and then we're going to get to more
complicated examples of systems of
ordinary differential equations so now
instead of keeping track of one variable
like the population of bunnies now maybe
I'm going to keep track of lots of
variables I care about maybe I am
keeping track of the population of
bunnies and wolves and you know a few
other species so I have a you know
multi-dimensional State X that has a few
components you know X1 X2 X3
and so now this differential equation is
going to be a matrix system of
differential equations where a is not a
number it's a matrix that tells me how
my my system changes in time as a linear
function of that system okay so systems
of Odes Builds on these simple ones but
very very important lots of examples
lots of cool things you can do with
systems of ordinary differential
equations you can model pendula masses
on Springs lots of cool systems you can
model
and I'm this is where the linear algebra
starts to come in so when we have
systems of ordinary differential
equations you know a is a matrix so
we're going to be talking about linear
algebra and that's essentially the study
of you know matrices and operators and
their properties
and specifically I'm going to derive the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this a
matrix
specifically as a useful set of
coordinates or a useful set of of
quantities that are used to solve the
system of Odes so we're going to show
what it means to make the system easy to
solve and we're going to find that the
way that we make that system easy to
solve is through an eigenvector
coordinate transformation so we're going
to derive eigenvalues and eigenvectors
and motivate them as how we solve
systems of Odes so if you took a linear
algebra class in the past and you were
confused by eigenvalues and eigenvectors
or you thought they were unmotivated
that couldn't be farther from the truth
they're very easy to understand they're
extremely well motivated
they are the way that we solve systems
of Odes
so I'll derive all of that from scratch
and then we're going to go to more
complicated differential equations so
instead of linear differential equations
where everything where the rate of
change of X is kind of linearly
proportional to the state X we're going
to talk about non-linear differential
equations nonlinear systems most of the
real world is actually non-linear so
when I talk about the populations of
bunnies and wolves you know bunnies or
prey and wolves or Predators They Don't
Really behave linearly there are
non-linear interactions that are
important to model and so we'll talk
about those non-linear systems that
chaotic example that movie I showed in
my first slide that's an example of a
the solution of a non-linear ordinary
differential equation and a lot of my
favorite systems really are in this uh
this realm here so the motion of the
planets and the solar system is a rich
chaotic non-linear system
your metabolism in your body is a
non-linear dynamical system you know
presumably your brain is a very high
dimensional complex non-linear system so
we'll talk about those as well
and throughout all of this I'm going to
be pinning this to numerics and
computations so we're not only going to
be talking about how do you do all of
this with pencil and paper or on a
whiteboard we're also going to you know
fire up Jupiter notebooks in python or
Matlab and we're going to work through
how do you actually simulate these
differential equations how can we plot
our Solutions and confirm that they
um you know match our intuition from
eigenvalues and eigenvectors okay so
everything I'm going to do is going to
be pinned to computations and I'm going
to do everything in Python everything in
Matlab all of the codes are going to be
online freely available and open okay so
you can kind of pick or choose your
language of choice
good uh so that that's the high level
overview this is again approximately
seven weeks about 20 hours a little bit
less than 20 hours of content I'm
planning and this fits into the larger
framework of
um you know engineering mathematics this
is the math you need to know if you want
to do you know real science and
engineering
um kind of at the next level Beyond
calculus
okay um and again I I always like to
point out you know a lot of what I'm
going to be telling you about is pretty
classical pretty analytic it can almost
feel a little dry or desiccated you know
some of it's hundreds of years old a few
hundreds of years old you know most of
the differential equations that we deal
with at least to begin with come from
things like Newton's f equals m a and
they're built on the calculus you know
that was around since Newton and leibniz
and so some of this you know can feel
pretty classical and that's okay that's
fine we're gonna you know we need to
build somewhere but we're going to use
these techniques these pencil and paper
techniques and I really find it
important I want you I want to convey to
you
how we use the intuition we get from
paper and pencil calculations for
advanced topics like now in the modern
era with computers we're not limited to
paper and pencil we can simulate very
very complex systems very high
dimensional very non-linear things you
could never solve by hand with paper and
pencil things that you know even Isaac
Newton couldn't solve analytically the
flow you know the fluid flow past a
cylinder we have to simulate this or run
experiments but the intuition we build
for the classic systems that you can
solve with paper with eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and linear systems and
things like that these ordinary
differential equations I'm going to
introduce you to we build a tremendous
amount of intuition for how the world
works and how differential equations and
dynamical systems how things change in
time from those analytic classic
Solutions and we're going to carry that
intuition with us when we do advanced
modern computational methods or even
more recently
data-driven analysis and machine
learning methods so it's very important
I'm not just telling you about things
that were discovered 300 years ago but I
want you to know how
we can take our you know analytics
Solutions things we can actually solve
in closed form and how we can translate
that to you know really hard Modern
Problems things like you know Advanced
simulations and advanced machine
learning models where you know no one
can write down the solution to these we
need computers for these but we can
still gain intuition from the classics
so that's a really important perspective
here of how that fits in
good okay
um so again this is the overview of
topics I've already walked you through
these
um and then the next thing I want to
tell you in this video is how this fits
in
to you know once you you learn this
material you invest this 20 hours what
does that open up to you what are the
next things and I have most of these uh
next steps actually filmed up so once
you learn this you can go kind of learn
the next things okay so what's next
um you know at least when I teach this
as a two-quarter sequence for my
students I have two weeks on complex
analysis so Solutions of differential
equations are naturally going to involve
um you know complex numbers and complex
functions so we'll spend you know not in
this sequence but in a future sequence
we'll spend two weeks of complex
analysis
uh we'll introduce Vector calculus and
partial differential equations so
generalizing these ordinary differential
equations which are just you know a
single derivative uh in terms of the
independent variable now we're going to
look at multiple derivatives uh of
different independent variables so I can
take you know derivatives of a function
in time and in space and relate those
that's what's known as partial
differential equation a partial
differential equation and that's
inherently built on the language of
vector calculus so this for me is
actually a unit Vector calculus and
partial differential equations go
together in the same way that ordinary
differential equations and linear
algebra go together so I'm actually
teaching this as a unit again that's
after this kind of intro to differential
equations you can then learn complex
analysis Vector calculus and pdes
uh we're also in this two-quarter
sequence going to introduce the Fourier
and Laplace transform
very closely related to differential
equations especially partial
differential equations and I'm not just
going to talk about kind of again
classic analytic you know hundreds of
years old Fourier and Laplace transforms
I'm also going to talk about how you do
this in a computer with Discrete Fourier
transforms and things like that how do
you use those for you know not just
solving differential equations how do
you use those for things like audio
processing or image compression so this
is kind of one of my favorite topics is
really this is transitioning from you
know differential equations and solving
physics problems to maybe solving data
science problems how do I compress
images and audio how do I do things like
that
and that segue is very naturally into
kind of and this is only a teaser in my
two-quarter uh engineering math sequence
but I have a you know whole kind of boot
camps and courses on this alone
once we have learned about Fourier
transforms and Laplace transforms and we
had that kind of understanding of what
linear algebra means it's really natural
to introduce modern data-driven
techniques
um you know data decompositions and
machine learning things like the
singular value decomposition which
generalize the Fourier transform to more
complex and Rich systems so this is
usually one of my students one of my my
favorite topics and one of the favorite
topics of my students when I teach it
this is kind of all culminating towards
these Advanced topics and I'll also
point out
the differential equations you're going
to learn in this sequence in this in
this course are going to be very very
applicable to control systems so if you
want to learn about control systems and
you want to kind of dive into the
control boot camp
this is the starting point is really
learning about differential equations
and linear algebra so that you feel
comfortable
so these are all of the topics that are
kind of opened up after you take this
course
so I'm super excited like for me this
opened up the whole world of engineering
applied math and physics and I hope uh
you know my dream this would be the
absolute best outcome is if even a small
fraction of you feel the same way that
this opens up possibilities for you as
well okay good so I hope you can tell
that like I love this I'm passionate
about it this is what I I want to do is
to teach you this math
okay so that's what's next
um and I think for the rest of this
video I'm just going to give you some
cool examples and applications of things
uh you know cool applications that you
can start studying and understanding
once you have a handle on differential
equations
you know one of my passions and and
Fields of Applied interest is fluid
mechanics I find fluids really
interesting because like literally we
live and work inside of a fluid and so
do all of our machines your heart is
pumping fluid through your veins
um you know every almost every trillion
dollar industry has a working fluid at
the heart of it if you think about
energy Transportation
defense Health you know all of these
have fluids wind turbines and you know
Automobiles and trains and planes and
cars all operate in fluids and at the
end of the day
fluid dynamics are governed by a set of
differential equations that you can
write down essentially it generalizes
Newton's second law of momentum
conservation to fluids okay so this is
an example of a differential equation
that we can understand and solve after
these techniques
some other cool examples of differential
equations that come up all the time
involve mixing so mixing is a really big
problem industrially and scientifically
how do you let's say you're trying to
make not acid let's say you're trying to
make aspirin not acid
maybe maybe you want to make acid but
you're making aspirin you know and a big
chemical vat and so you're adding all
these ingredients and you want to mix
them as efficiently as possible you know
how do you put in stirring rods and
things like that to mix this system as
efficiently as possible again this is a
dynamical system uh that that is
governed by a set of differential
equations you know that tell you how the
system is going to mix so that chaotic
low rents a tractor I showed you in my
first slide that's an example of a
chaotic system that mixes uh efficiently
in time
uh and and once you you understand how
to solve differential equations you can
do things like Drop little test
particles in these fluid systems in
these Vector Fields so this is a
jellyfish and this is one of my cool one
of my favorite examples where
researchers actually measure the vector
field kind of the fluid flow Field
behind this jellyfish using uh you know
measurement techniques experimental
measurement techniques and then
thinking about that fluid Vector field
or velocity field as a differential
equation you can think of where little
food particles would add vect in that in
that differential equation you could
integrate those forward along this
differential equation and figure out
where they'll go
and so for example uh Sean shad and John
DeBerry and Jerry Marsden in this really
really cool paper showed that by
integrating these particles you can find
Regions where some particles get ejected
into the propulsive wake of the
jellyfish whereas other particles these
green particles get kind of entrained
into the Bell or the feeding region and
so again this is they were using
differential equations and the same
exact techniques I'm going to teach you
about in this series to integrate these
test particles and to make this kind of
scientific discovery of how jellyfish
eat
I can't help myself I'm also going to
show this really cool kind of follow-on
work uh by by John DeBerry and kit
Parker where they actually design a
mechanical jellyfish this is using I
believe tissue from a mouse or a rat
heart some rodent heart
that they put in a fluid that has
electrolytes and they're going to pulse
this electrolyte solution and kind of
get this artificial jellyfish to uh to
swim so this is when they start pulsing
the the fluid you know they they put
current through that fluid and this
thing starts to pulse and again you can
understand this is a dynamical system it
has a state that varies in time
according to rules f equals m a kinds of
rules and so you can write down a
differential equation and understand how
to design and optimize and predict the
motion of this this system
uh other things you can do with
differential equations is understand you
know
geophysical flows ocean flows climate
systems
um you know things like if there's a an
oil spill in the Gulf of Mexico where is
that oil going to go can you predict uh
you know where things are going to go
and have your models match again based
on these differential equations and
solution techniques to those
differential equations
um this is a cool simulation uh that I
like by Philip dutois where he applied
that same basic analysis to the entire
Global ocean model to figure out where
our regions where mixing occurs and
where mixing doesn't occur and things
like that again using basic techniques
and differential equations that I'll
tell you about in this class
for me fluids is really interesting but
the whole world is not just fluids there
are you know climate processes and
chemical processes you know combustion
processes those are all systems that
change in time according to rules and
that's all that a differential equation
is is a set of rules for how your system
changes in time
uh good so in this we will also touch on
chaos I've already eluded you know chaos
for me is one of the most fascinating
topics in all of Applied math because it
comes up so often when we analyze
systems maybe they seem to be orderly
um for some parameters and when you
change a parameter it becomes very
chaotic and unpredictable so that's you
know something we'll talk about is how
can you simulate these systems how can
you diagnose chaos how do you handle it
numerically what are some of the tools
to analyze it
um you know it turns out that the solar
system the planets in the solar system
have chaotic motion which I think is
kind of interesting so they appear to be
going around in ellipses around the sun
which is true
but if you are a a satellite or if you
want to send a space probe to Jupiter
there are these kind of chaotic
trajectories that you can leverage for
energy efficient space travel which is
one of my favorite examples of a
dynamical system again a lot of our
knowledge of dynamical systems you know
if you go back to Newton and and leibniz
and kind of the classics a lot of this
was motivated by understanding you know
planets in the solar system and a lot of
research still uh goes into to this this
topic
um I'll talk about things like you know
double pendula this is one of my
favorite tabletop examples of a chaotic
dynamical system so this is actually me
in a lecture in person about 10 years
ago and this is my uh double pendulum
setup that I built I'm just going to run
this again
good maybe I'll even bring that into
this lightboard studio I'm trying to
figure out where I would mount it you
know I'm going to give you a lecture on
chaos and the double pendulum uh what it
means and how to simulate it things like
that
if you have these differential equations
and you understand how to use them you
can do things like do control design and
actually you know harness the Dynamics
and overcome that chaos to do things
like stabilize you know a trajectory
that you want and it's super interesting
humans walking so I am an inverted
double pendulum approximately as a
walker if you you know shot novocaine or
lidocaine into my legs I'd fall over
because I'm unstable I'm approximately
stable right now sometimes I'm more
unstable than others and you know so
even like humans walking and bio
Locomotion very much a dynamical system
governed by differential equations and
we can understand how to control those
systems and how to analyze those systems
again you know using the techniques from
this class
um and once you can control these
systems you can do things like
Rehabilitation medicine you can also do
things like you know Landing a rocket
this is an inverted pendulum control
system that you're trying to you know
you're trying to land this inverted
pendulum with as little control as
possible so again this is a pretty good
example of a differential equation that
we want to write down and analyze and
eventually control
the combustion in the rocket engine also
a dynamical system you know the wind
flowing over this thing the fluid flow
environment also a differential equation
so it really is kind of a rich uh almost
everything you can think of as a
differential equation at the end of the
day and except things that are static
and don't move okay you hope your bridge
that you build is not a dynamical system
but everything else really is
okay good I'm trying to think if there's
anything else that's really the very
high level I've been looking forward to
this class for a long time
um you know I've been teaching this for
10 years this is one of the things I'm
most passionate about and I'm super
super excited to you know to give this
to a broader audience
um you know please let me know what's
confusing what made sense what you liked
what you didn't like you know this is
going to be a living set of lectures
again all of the resources are going to
be made open you know PDFs of the notes
and all of the codes
um
I'm excited to walk you through all of
this
um you know I'm going to try to release
all of these videos pretty soon so
you're going to see this and then
hopefully within a very short amount of
time all of this is going to be
following so I'll also have playlists
again in the description so you can go
to that playlist so you don't get lost
about where you know what's the next
video you can kind of follow this in in
the right order
uh good okay um just some sneak peeks of
things I'm going to show you because I
have a little bit of time left
um you know I'm gonna again I've already
mentioned this but this is one of my
absolute favorite lectures to give
because it made so much sense to me it
was something I struggled with and I had
bad explanation after bad explanation
and you know it finally clicked when I
started thinking about eigenvalues and
eigenvectors as a coordinate
transformation so eigenvectors the
eigenvectors of of a matrix is a
coordinate transformation
it's a matrix that changes my
coordinates so that my differential
equation x dot equals ax becomes
diagonal which means it's easy to solve
so you know this is just a teaser I'm
going to have a whole lecture on this
but I'm really excited to share the
intuition you know about how eigenvalues
and eigenvectors I think are best
understood when you think about solving
differential equations and when you want
to solve differential equations
eigenvalues and eigenvectors are like
your most powerful tools that's how we
think about and analyze and understand
all of the Dynamics of these
differential equations so this is going
to be a killer lecture another one you
know I'm going to show you how you take
a fluid flow like this you know how you
write down the differential equation
let's say I have a little particle here
I drop a little dust particle X and it
moves around in this fluid flow field U
so U is literally a velocity field a
vector field that varies in Space X and
in time t
and we're going to look at how that
velocity field that Vector field of the
fluid is a differential equation for how
a passive particle would move if I drop
a little dust particle or a smoke
particle and in this class we're going
to look at how to numerically integrate
those test particles forward throughout
that flow field and extract really
interesting useful quantities like these
cool movies and other things like it
for now you know stay tuned this is
going to be a lot we're going to build
up real simple you know from basic
calculus that you either have seen or
hopefully remember and then we're going
to hit the ground running it's going to
go slow but it's going to build up quick
and it's going to open up a huge huge
set of engineering applied math
possibilities so I'm super excited stay
tuned and I'll see you next time thanks
foreign
[Music]